[Music]
michael from florida
michael welcome to the ramsay show
thank you how are y'all doing doing good
i see i see the word pool coming up so i
thought well that'd be a great place for
old kyle to have there's a lot of
weddings
how can we help michael
i'm trying to get some advice as to
whether or not my wife and i are making
a financial mistake by putting an
in-ground pool on our property okay
so we have the money to cash flow it we
have no debt other than our home
we bought our house right before covet
topped off pretty strong two years ago
the house we were living at flyer had a
pool
and it's something that we both want and
enjoyed having um i just don't know if
i'm terrified about spending the money
she's not she's all over
michael put in a pool
michael don't put in a pool i'm just
kidding
hey how much how much do you owe in your
house
so currently uh the mortgage is about
182 but with the way property values and
everything has gone in our area we're
sitting
on a
piece of property worth upwards of 350
at the moment but so you owe 180 left on
your mortgage
that's correct
oh this 60 would bring you down to 120
and then a couple more hard months and
you're at five digits man
that is exactly what i tried to tell my
wife that she sit back sat back a little
bit i know that we could have that house
paid off in less than five years
that was my goal do you all have kids
yes what are their ages
two daughters one is six and it'll be 18
the other one's sticking to the 11.
18 and 11. that what you just said
yes that's correct oh so this pool is
for y'all it's not even for them
wow yeah
for the 11 year old yeah the 11 year old
to use it the 18 year old may not so
much
here so i i don't think there's there's
not a there's not a right or wrong here
here's the deal here's the one that
might be split on it rachel rachel's all
about pools she loves a pool
and i've never had one so i just go to
other people's pools i've never had a
pool either i've never had a house with
a pool no you haven't no oh okay
my parents moved into a house at the
pool when i left for college so it
doesn't count that's a good move i don't
count yeah
but um
yeah because here's the deal michael you
guys
you're out of debt you're funding your
retirement you have your emergency fund
and yes obviously the house is the next
big thing so yeah run the numbers and
say okay let's say we paid it off
oh you know and took the 60 grand
instead of a pool that but to me it's 60
grand which actually is a kind of a an
ex like some pools i've heard are like
insane like yeah it's crazy so it's a
stone worker this is like a nice car
this would be like you know i'm saying
like the 60 grand so
if it was 200 000 michael i think mike i
think my answer would probably be even
would be different
60 grand you have the cash for it
you got your 11 year old
and we'll still have
honestly well over our three to six
month emergency fund how much do you
make a year did i how much do you make a
year all right
our base is 115 but with the bonuses
that my wife consistently gets we're
closer to about 120. okay pay your house
off faster maybe you split the
difference say i'll get this but we're
going to put our house on a on a on a 24
36 month payoff and so i'll trade you
the pool before we're hitting the gas
we're not going out to eat anymore we're
gonna get this house paid off and we're
gonna get it done and so then you both
you look up in three years and you both
won
there you go
compromise this is the worst
[Music]